have you ever walked out of a building
on a sunny day and had an uncontrollable
urge to sneeze
[Music]
if you answered yes like me you likely
suffer from a strange genetic condition
that has remained unexplained by medical
science for millennia
and if you answered no you probably have
no idea what i'm talking about
sun sneezing as it's more commonly known
is a medical condition called the photic
sneeze reflex another name that some
have given is hold on before we get into
all that this is dr louis patacek a
neurologist and human geneticist at the
university of california san francisco
okay go ahead another name that some
have given is autosomal dominant
compelling
heliophthalmic outburst or achoo
syndrome but psr is really the
appropriate name that we should all use
photic sneeze reflexes a tendency to
sneeze when suddenly exposed to bright
light
and as strange as that may sound it's
more common than you might think i
estimate that about one in ten or ten
percent of all people have this
condition
so a lot of us are affected but how and
why it happens is not fully understood
despite the fact that humans have been
pondering it for thousands of years
in 350 bc aristotle posed the question
why does the heat of the sun provoke
sneezing
aristotle was barking up the wrong tree
though
this doesn't make sense because
heat in and of itself doesn't cause
sneezing some 2000 years later the
philosopher sir francis bacon also tried
to figure it out his theory was that
light from the sun caused your eyes to
water which then seep into your nose
triggering a sneeze
it's an interesting thought but it
doesn't make a lot of sense psr occurs
almost instantaneously and it takes
longer for the tear ducts to react
furthermore tears
don't cause sneezing
there's no evidence for that so modern
medicine has come up with its own
theories and it has to do with the
wiring in your head sneezes are
triggered typically by irritating things
in our nose and these are detected by a
nerve the trigeminal nerve and right
next door to the trigeminal nerve is the
optic nerve you may have heard of this
one the optic nerve is stimulated by
bright light and sends electric signals
to the brain some of that signal can be
picked up by the trigeminal nerve and
misinterpreted by the brain as an
irritation in the nose which triggers
you guessed it a sneeze well that's the
theory anyway photic sneeze reflex is
not a disease consequently the medical
community hasn't paid a whole lot of
attention to it therefore we know very
little about what causes it but dr
pitacic believes that understanding psr
could potentially shed some light on
more serious conditions
epileptic seizures can be caused by
strobing lights migraine headache is
precipitated by light if we can
understand what the mechanism is that
leads to psr this may give insights into
other conditions which actually are
medically important and represent
disorders so there you have it this 2000
year old medical mystery may be worth
solving after all